c'est quand même la première fois jeudi
ce n'est que je vois une addition
gratuit c'est complètement gratuit
incroyable bourde désir
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on vous parle directement
depuis le disney store on va vous parler
elle demande plus du one + 7 ouais je
veux bien parler de lui cette cession
one boxing ont fait pas anonymes boxing
on est bientôt là est ce que on est pas
mal avec au chaud comme ça moi c'est
stylé un frisson top style et messieurs
c'est pas le top 15 de meilleurs
produits qu'on trouve à disney village
calme et qui a rien compris
coupez-les je vous emmène aujourd'hui à
marne-la-vallée on à disneyland paris
mais dans le disney village pour vous
parler d'une puce est alors vous me
direz quel est le rapport entre disney
village genuine plus est il absolument
aucun l'idée c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya
un salon plutôt btu by day qui s'appelle
haiti partners
je vais aller y faire un tour et en
attendant je me suis dit je vais quand
même vous parlez d'un smartphone qui va
sortir d'ici quelques temps là la pluie
arrive ça fait un bien fou ça rafraîchit
on est parfaitement bien on n'a peur de
rien va quand même vous parler
aujourd'hui du smartphone du wan plus
est alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
que vous ne plus sortir cette année de
smartphones nous en doutaient louane
plus est est loin de plus ces pts et un
peu plus tard le plus c'était mais aussi
un troisième smartphone ce sera le one +
5 g parce que one plus c'est vraiment
acteurs de la 5g j'ai pu les voir
notamment au mwc parlait justement de la
5g et on voyait rapidement le smartphone
le one + 5 g alors ça c'est un
smartphone sortira pas forcément pour
l'instant france parce que la 5g en
avoir 30 son temps les opérateurs sont
pas encore prêts probablement à
l'horizon 2020-2021 la 5g va
démocratiser donc on va vraiment ce
focus est pour l'instant sur ce point de
plus 7
alors ce qu'on a vraiment vu en 2018
c'était l'encoche sur le wan +6 ou en
plus 6t 2019 c'est la disparition de
l'encoche et on devrait avoir une petite
caméra pop up comme vous avez sur le vix
von hexe c'est tous des infos je trouve
notamment sur cela schilick sur only qs
donc tout des fuites des rumeurs mais
franchement ça nous permet de dresser un
portrait-robot assez précis de ce qu'on
devrait retrouver cette année au niveau
du vote plus est comme forcément il y
aura pas de petite caméra invisible elle
sortira et rentrera en fonction de vos
besoins pour les vous chutez ans elle
fuit on va avoir un capteur d'empreintes
digitales comme on a vu sur nous on peut
citer le sauf que cette fois ci ça
serait très probablement un capteur
empreintes digitales ultrasonique tout
simplement parce que ce
one + 7 sera équipé du snapdragon 855
qui est le socle le plus performant de
paul comme et qui gère justement ce
capteur d'empreinte ultras sont donc
plus rapide plus sécurisé et plus cool
et moi il pleut je me protège un peu ça
on est pas mal
simplement quand smartphones très
performants c'est vraiment la dn1 de
toute façon besoin de plus et vous
proposer le meilleur des technologies à
des tarifs vraiment pas cher on devrait
avoir un smartphone qui devrait avoir
entre 6 à 12 giga de ram 128 à 256 go de
stockage extensible jusqu'à normalement
512 à vérifier une grosse batterie de
4000 à 4150 milliampères heures avec de
la recharge rapide la tâche charge
probablement de la recharge 44 soit une
recharge en usb tc et toujours pas de
recharge
alors il pleut il fait soleil allez
savoir et toujours pas de recharge sans
fil sur ce smartphone un design avec des
coins toujours arrondi un très grand
écran qui devrait occuper 95% de la face
avant qu'une caméra placée au dos
vraiment au centre un smartphone qui
fera street 9.5 mm d'épaisseur un écran
justement d'écrans amoled 6,5 pouces
résolution full hd + et bien évidemment
complètement optimisé pour le gaming
pour le multimédia une expérience
visuelle top parce que vous n'auriez
absolument rien pas d'encoches pas de
mule pas de doute rien du tout au niveau
des photos vous auriez un triple module
arrière nous aurions une caméra de 48
vega pixels prend ce moment là la sony
mx 5 186 et qui vous permettrait d'avoir
la technologie quadpixel en main qui
serait notamment excellente pour la
photo de nuit après avoir avec le
traitement logiciel que nous offrira le
plus derrière une caméra 20 mégapixels
peut-être un grand-angle
allez savoir ou alors un zoom x 2 à voir
et une caméra de 5 mégapixels pour le
mode portrait à l'avant dans ce type au
peuple dans ce petit caméra escamotable
on dort une caméra de 16 mégapixels tous
attendre et sur un oxygène os 9 sur un
android 9 taille alors sur ce modèle là
on aura pas de prise jack
elle a déjà disparu notamment avec le
one plus ce système est par contre loin
de plus a vraiment dit travailler sur
des écouteurs sans fil donc je pense que
cette année en même temps que l'annoncé
du gain de +7 on pouvait avoir des
petits écouteurs sans fil soit des intra
auriculaires soit des bugs à voir un peu
ce que parle concocté one plus là dessus
un smartphone qui sera présenté en mai à
2019 je vous en reparlerai très très
prochainement dont je vous invite à vous
abonner
aujourd'hui comme ça vous saurez tout
dessus et on a même une image de coqs
qui a fuité sur slash l'x our préfecture
mansat confirme en tout cas c'est
vraiment s'enfermer
le design du produit la petite place qui
est laissé en haut de la coque pour la
caméra escamotable ça semble vraiment
très intéressant alors voilà plus pour
ce portrait robot de sewen +7 dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez
est ce que c'est un smartphone que vous
attendez est-ce que vous avez déjà les
les modèles de l'année dernière loin de
+6 lorraine +6 ts que ce soit ne plus
être pourrez vous tentez vous marquez
tout ça en commentaire et là je vous
emmène avec moi on est à disneyland
le salon c'est haïti partners et la
regarde et on en profite on a le soleil
juste derrière là on est devant le lego
store qui est juste là il ya plein plein
de trucs cool donc au programme
aujourd'hui je vous en parle pas
forcément mais c'est d'aller visiter
découvrir un peu ce salon qui ce soir
allez faire un tour d'attraction ça
c'est plutôt cool on va vous les gars là
on va disney et là on va au hit &
partners un petit salon professionnel
histoire de rencontrer des boîtes de la
tech on est déjà à disney en ait la
chaire produits et comment ça se passe
on a déjà fait le disney store ça t'a
rendu complètement fou guillaume les
rumeurs je l'a empêché de sortir sa
carte on va y aller jusqu'à 23 heures
pour aller se faire déchirer et ça va
être bien nous voilà quelques heures
après exactement au même endroit on avec
guillaume l'ammonium on est fatigués
surtout toi soirée privatisée au parc
disneyland paris c'est juste magnifique
et plus gros
on va bien manger bien voilà mais on va
vous montrer tout ça donc valera ça va
être franchement cool là combien briques
de lego là dessus la 230 civils brice a
fait 800 kg et là on a matière de d2
tout en lego juste des trucs et en fait
c'est tout fissible et aurait pu faire
sur la toile attirant 1 5 mille briques
hélas si vous êtes fans de toy story
voilà vous avez tenté à toi tu pourrais
être en lego toi nasa et vous avez même
de la belle déco avec la belle et la
bête
et là vous avez un dragon qui rentre là
qui peuvent par la kirb passe par là qui
repose par là on a reçu des boîtes
severino dans celle ci était pas allé
voir mon article pour les sera dans la
description et lancerait la visite de
tous les stores disney on se faire en
version très très rapide mais il ya
franchement tout cas c'est cool qu'est
ce que tu as trouvé ce que la youtube
renie va acheter très clair tout
l'intérêt de cette soirée réside quand
même dans le fait que on à l'entrée au
parc qui est gratuite ce soir là le parc
et sans que
[Musique]
alors tu es chaud
chaud patate
on trouve à la sortie elle commence en
faction
à sa fille mais pas on recommence parce
qu'en fait j'ai pas fini mais là je suis
pas une seule caméra
alors monsieur voulait aller à aerosmith
nous est très beau show pour ça du coup
on a appris ça cameron a pris son sac
aux deux affaires et puis on va les
bouffer au restaurant qui est merde il
est juste là le restaurant on va les
manger un coût puisque d'attraction ça
me tente pas à pas tout
bon apparemment à il a fini il arrive
alors c'est fat à cesser leurs patins
vrai ça va ça fait pas trop pas
honnêtement oui c'est l'effroi cool non
franchement c'est à dire tu as les
loopings sa toiture actuelle mais
franchement ça va ça va 30 c'est un peu
court
un bloco 25 on a attendu quoi deux
minutes je peux faire la tournée terreur
échos moi je vais sur les petits bateaux
à des mots elle est bien gérée truc tout
mais on tombe dans un ascenseur
franchement ça va ça va entendu 17
agents recenseurs d'affaires je les fais
ya trois ans bref j'étais bourré
heureusement des organes qui remonte
organe qui remonte j'ai pas une descente
d'organes j'ai une remontée d'organes
nationale vous nous fait les boutiques
tout acheter à part manger pas faire une
mise au point qui va recommencer
du coup nous ont fait les boutiques 1d
dans son ascenseur votre mourir hyper
large
franchement j'étais bien c'est pas d'un
an nettement c'est sainté sans plusieurs
princesse c'est quand même la première
fois chez disney que je vois une
addition gratuit c'est complètement
gratuit
incroyable on désire bon merci c'était
très sympa cette petite soirée
disneyland complètement offertes un
marat qui partait en s'activant au mr
said it partners concernant le one piece
fait il faisait quand même le sujet de
la vidéo on se marre qu'on dise terme
dit pas tout ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire et plus jeunes rendez vous
demain de bisous bisous saluent bien
saluons ryan gosling et si jamais vous
voulez un top 15 des pierres produite et
storm des poussées nous un commentaire
ciao